all odds we have returned the haters
have been
on our tail saying these guys
will never show their face again and to
them i say
take a good hard look at this mug
some people say it's a mug only a mother
love could love and i'm here to say
also my wife loves it or so she says you
look quiet
i know that's it no no more support
after that i set you up for a little
complimentary comment but
no that's right i'll live dude you look
[ __ ]
i can't see the f word this early has it
been 30 seconds dan
all right i just ruined the hole i just
ruined the whole episode
by doing that but you know what it was
you just looked so good i couldn't
control myself
sorry yeah it's your fault
i'm gonna punish you later girl stop
and uh that's actually a good segue into
saying that we have
now our teddy fresh black friday sale is
live
right now this is
your one time to get teddy fresh on
discount
fat discount 30 to 50 off the entire
website
there are no plans of any restocks so
now it's now
over at all this is the end of teddy
fresh going out of business so
well we just have we have we have all
news we have new stuff
we plan monthly releases and
um everything on the website will never
come back
pretty much it's all fresh from here
thank you all members by the way we love
you we appreciate you
guys thank you thank you thank you the
members are so important to what we do
here
thank you so yeah head on over to
teddyfresh.com and just browse and see
if there's anything you like because the
discounts are so deep and so hot
you want to show them though sure i'll
show it
god this last 24 hours was an insane
[ __ ] show
yeah the week it was a night so we were
working
i love this animation by the way we one
of our illustrators is such a
mega talent um i love him his name is
eli he's the best
wait animates no no illustration well
we made it so like it's a swipe so it's
like dark on instagram and all you see
is
his eyes and then you swipe over like
you turn on the lights
i can show it on instagram if anyone
cares yeah i'll show it
i mean i don't know if that yeah
hey let's keep it moving keep it
moving
anyway everything is 30 to 50 off deep
discounts here's the sweater ela's
wearing by the way
45 dollars instead of 75 that's insane
that's the only time you ever can get it
in this stuff
but anyway we were up at uh including
the color block and all your
all the favorites everything's on sale
spongebob
patchwork it's all the good [ __ ] the
three-way panel
it's all on sale um so we had this huge
launch planned at 12 and and
we have an app yeah 12 o'clock midnight
and we have this app
that basically converts all the products
like you you do all the changes you want
and then at 12 you hit this app and then
it's supposed to update all the products
instantaneously so it's like okay it's
black friday now
except for some [ __ ] reason
the app when it was updating the website
removed all the sizes
also it took way longer than instant it
took like 40 minutes
far from [ __ ] so that was i was like
oh great
because there was like 10 000 people on
the site waiting to buy
and nothing was happening and i was like
watching people bouncing and i was like
oh
this is awful hey honey get the [ __ ] off
my site there's no coupons for you
here um
honey's such a [ __ ] by the way as a as
a i love honey but let me tell you
because sometimes you you do a code for
somebody and then honey's like i got it
everybody gets it
so it's like we have to fight versus
honey now they're too good at what they
yeah
sons of [ __ ] it's
crazy and so um
so not only did it take long but then
when it finished all the sizes
were gone yeah all the sizes were gone
i've never seen anything like it you
would just click a product and it would
say
there's no sizes so either would say
sold out
even though there was like other sizes
or it would just you wouldn't
people were buying stuff and they didn't
know what sizes they were getting yeah
they're just like i'll take this and
then so
you know what i mean and well i don't
blame them because they look i feel so
bad for people who are up waiting
no they're that committed yeah no
they're like i'm just gonna buy this and
see what happens
because then they email support and say
okay well i bought it can you send me a
large please and then
so our support team is working hard
there's four people working super hard
it's just it's a support nightmare for
them now but we'll figure it out and
we're figured out we're making good
on everyone but it was just a long night
and also it was already 1am
so everyone that usually helps us with
like
shopify tech questions were already
asleep
so we were calling our poor programmer
it was 1am and i was like oh god
you know what i even dm the [ __ ] i've
talked with the president
of spotif or shopify before
we've we've talked a few times and i and
i dm'd him on twitter at 1 am i was like
hey you up
he has not uh returned my dm anybody
who's curious
i was like hey you up
but we figured it out we figured it out
we got the sizes back
yeah yeah so we were really well i think
what i learned basically is don't
launch at 12 o'clock ever ever
because [ __ ] always happens yeah this is
the joy of running a business especially
online you just never know what the
[ __ ] gonna happen
but anyway hope you enjoy the sale if
you have
any issues just hit up the support email
they're
going to be working extra hours
we have four people working around
making sure everyone gets help
yeah sort it all out
okay that's enough of that also i want
to say congratulations
i just peed in my basement and speaking
of the quartering i wanted to
congratulate
the whole team on the content courts
the newest content court on the ab
family has been doing really good
i don't know what family ace family i'm
sorry i'm not the ab family
in my family you just you just spoiled
it no actually
we're content according to you next week
i know about your family bro
oh god damn no there's the ab family
that i'm friendly with
and i am and i don't want him to think
i'm coming i'm not coming after them
um ace family is actually doing really
good and
you know i it might not look like much
but
we work a lot like we take we spend like
a lot of time preparing these
and researching and the powerpoints and
everything and so
it's nice to see people enjoying it
because there's actually a lot of work
that goes into these
so good job to everybody good job to a b
ian zach dan congratulations to the
whole team
for making some really good content
thank you thank you
it was fun stop also another
announcement is
make ethan laugh we were premiering it
we were supposed to do it this week but
there was just way too much
chaos in my life um so
this coming wednesday at 12 o'clock we
will be doing make ethan laugh
live that's where we're gonna have
people call in they're going to try to
make me laugh
they make me laugh they want 100 bucks
we already have we have calls lined up
if you want to be eligible just become a
member because zach vets people on
discord it's gonna be a lot of fun i'm
super excited
who wants to be a millionaire who wants
to be
you know howard stern used to do this
but who wants to be his zimbabwe
millionaire
it was like seven cents or something or
like seven dollars
so maybe we can do who wants to be a
zimbabwe trillionaire
what is this animation epic animation by
youtube channel tom
have you not seen it yet no oh boy here
we go
i got no audio hang on
technical difficulties we've got no
audio audio we've got no
audi we've got no audio
dan what's up we've got no sound
we've got no sound to hear
i need sound to listen to a video
otherwise it doesn't make any sense
damn what's up you want me to read some
donations
audio sound is required
for the show to go where's the sound
go ahead uh legend of grid for ten
dollars so just realize that youtube
rewind is coming in a few weeks
hold on zach do your thing
ah rewind time ah that's hot
that's hot
[Laughter]
he says i think it will be cringy what
do you guys think i
oh we think audio thank you dan um
rewind time
we're never well
i guess one time we were slightly
invited why we were invited last year
yeah
i call it slightly invited well the
thing is like they invite us but they
just want us to be doing the irish
i always say it was like it's just
embarrassing
because it's like they do it and jake
and logan paul
are taking up fifty percent of the whole
thing and then they're like here's ethan
kline doing the irish jig with 50 other
youtubers you don't know
yeah and then i'm just in the background
like like a ghost in the background
you know it's like i could rewind and be
involved in that
that's why i call it slightly invited
that's not really inviting at best
you'll be like casey
neistat going k-pop
that's pretty good though compared to
like a ghost dancing in the background
that's an iconic moment at this point
they'll have me doing like
in the background that will ruin all my
abilities so wait so this year so we
aren't even invited for like
nobody approached me
i think they got the message i wonder
who they'll put in it though because all
the big creators people care about are
just
totally embroiled embroiled in
controversy
yeah it's like nobody is family friendly
anymore
oh i guess you i mean you've got like
let's think david dobreck is
i i mean david dobrik is is good maybe
i'll get the ace family
ace family i need that clout he's like
you know be funny if there's a shot of
the ace family like he's shooting a
basketball
and then as it's going towards the the
rim it just turns into dollar bills
oh yeah it's probably going to be all
about mr beast oh mr beast yeah he's the
golden child
yeah there's no controversy
family-friendly content it'll just be a
mr beast video
they should just let mr beast make
youtube rewind that'd be sick maybe they
did
mr beast if you're watching this i'll do
an irish jig in your [ __ ]
your rewind
but to be not easy but to be honest
there hasn't really i don't think
there'll be a better rewind than will
smith one because it's so iconically bad
ah why are you so negative
ah fortnight fortnight fortnite
you can't stop that
that was like such a frenzy when that
came out
i kind of do want it to be cringy and
crazy like that one was if i'm being
honest i think that's better that's true
that's true
they shouldn't listen to any of the
criticism the problem is that the year
after they were so uh they had like so
much
trauma yeah that they were just like
okay here's the facts
and then it was just everyone's like we
hate you [ __ ] you
this you know if i was youtube i'd be
like [ __ ] you i'm done with this [ __ ]
rerun yourself [ __ ] rewind yourself
back into your mom's womb
i mean should they even still make them
i think they should just go
all out will smith style yeah make them
as cringe as possible
yeah like everybody got so upset but
that's like iconic got him
they should get zach
yeah zach zack is an icon he does he
zach belongs in
and uh rewind i appreciate that
do you also remember last year when they
hold on photo shoot hold on
there needs to be more smiling to
seriousness like
got him like that
go ahead zach sorry got him
when they photoshopped the teddy fresh
off of your
uh oh yeah i forgot oh
they thought of they totally did
yeah they didn't they didn't know how to
clear it they didn't have the
they didn't know how to clear it you
know
it was out of the budget got him all
right let's watch this animation wait
hold on one second oh
still is there no bottles i have sound
but now i've got
i've got i've got all kinds of you got
any other questions
maybe oh yeah tonight there's been some
other ones
i'll just need a minute to fortnite sort
this out
fortnite uh fortnite
a b you got anything for me for tonight
a b are you anybody here what's the i
was on you i was on
you from lucas for ten dollars yeah i
mean come on this i mean
tell me about your mute button yeah why
are you unmuted
i'm muting myself so you're kidding me
nerf commercials
he's overcompensated from before yeah
you've gone too far yeah
all right what do we got luke he's for
ten dollars he says hey peeps i'm from
brazil we love you here i'm dying to buy
teddy fresh tea
do you guys ship to brazil love you
um we have a few countries that we do we
not
banned because of the because like 50 of
the packages go missing
right and so it's always like we're just
refunding so many customers that we're
losing money shipping to that country
so i don't know actually if we ship to
brazil i'll check
but um but if you write customer support
they'll let you know
kyle roland he says can you give me my
sister
uh he put my sister i and my girlfriend
maria a shout out
got myself a few bits on teddy fresh
today so feeling extra generous
he just wants to shout out one of my
[ __ ] shout outs what am i a clown
i hear like a song and dance man
i don't like doing shout outs i don't
know what a shout out means it's like
what do i say
i don't like doing shout outs because
it's like you know
we're trying to do a show here no i'm
not blaming you ab i mean thank you for
the donation and stuff it's just like
let's just do this is the shout out show
shout out to
kyle and his girlfriend everybody shout
out for the island
shout out to the island man shout out to
the island
might be going live we're live right now
not sure
guys we're back you know we would always
be back we are back
is it up you see it i see myself looking
at my phone
but i'm assuming you know what shame on
those of you who left
those good thing comes to those who who
hold and wait and have faith
you know we'll always come back you
think we're just going to bounce
[ __ ] no okay
okay so just uh i guess just to explain
to the audience what just happened our
uh
switching software um that we've been
using since i came on board pretty much
in 2017
just uh hard crashed which has
never happened so fortnite first time
for everything so
well we're back and so this will just be
one vaude right dan
yeah i didn't create a new event or
anything it's just gonna come out i love
that
and we can probably just snip that out
and post and yeah then no one will be
the wiser
people are gonna want to see that yeah
we're gonna snip out the dancing the
dancing was kind of iconic
but i'll say there was just a lot of is
this a lot should we leave it okay who
cares that's a decision for another
moment in time let's watch this [ __ ]
animation we were waiting for
can we all agree if this sound doesn't
work i'm gonna i'm gonna lose it
i'm about to click it hit play for a
second
all right all right we got you here we
go guys we got sound
[Applause]
[Music]
these guys look so fun yeah
[Music]
do i run like uh do i get the anime run
on
dude
[Music]
this is long boy let's go
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is insanely good
[Music]
hey
[Music]
who made that some guy named
who thomas he's an awesome fan tom
[ __ ] crush
tom that was everything wait there's
only 400 views on this yeah uh he posted
on the subreddit it didn't get that much
traffic it only has like 130 up votes
everybody should go up vote this on the
subject yeah let me find out what's
going on on this why this
oh i'm not logged in but where's this
post i gotta make it it was on the front
page this morning
it just didn't have all that that was
the greatest thing i've ever seen yeah
it's unbelievably cool
i'm kind of afraid of scrolling the
subreddit unvetted because the [ __ ] gets
weird wow i don't have it on screen oh
okay wow that was
everything isn't that phrase so useful
now yeah
i start i find myself saying that it's i
feel like such a douche when i say it
it's no everything is everything i feel
like someone on the bachelorette
that was like everything i love seeing
it now
okay well okay well that's an hour later
we've gotten through all of our
housekeeping
now i wanted to move on as all of you
probably have been following or many of
you
some of you sane among us maybe just
don't follow the election and that's
fine and that's a good idea i
unfortunately have been doom watching
the past like 72 hours is it yeah 72 or
long is it longer
i wanted to just turn it off and just
tell me when there's a result
well there's a result this morning and
it's pretty much gg
donald trump gigi no ree that's a
[ __ ] gg
and but anyway okay actually i'm happy
to say
you know people were saying that there
was like going to be riots and this and
people were going to be
outside the election with guns and all
and all this
and so far it's not been that i mean it
all went pretty smooth i think
which i'm you know for the most part so
far
but there were some really funny goofs
that i wanted to share with you
first first of all louis vuitton you
know they got to keep it real
these [ __ ]
[Music]
wow i really like the ratio
perfect well just how i like to view my
videos
okay tick tock's website is the word bro
i can't even full screen
you're like way zoomed in stop zoom out
they're like okay
if you're not gonna use our app we're
just not gonna let you
see they shouldn't even have gonna be
like unusable
yeah that probably is their strategy
yeah so
so louis vuitton got and i guess i don't
know that brand hermes
do you know that brand it's like
high-end yeah louis vuitton's got their
own custom um
plywood uh riot pro flywheel
why does it look so good because it's
louis vuitton they're like you know the
right you
if you're getting virgil too if you're
getting looted
i'm gonna look good in style boy i love
it can you believe these [ __ ]
hermes did it too they should write on
it plywood
and quotes i'll get all artistic
yeah i just thought that was so funny
that they put up designer plywood
so shout out to louis vuitton for
keeping it street keeping
it keeping it uh and the experience it's
an experience no matter what the
experience
is the looters are like damn
nice so that was good
here's a little clip of uh
some of the best that election
past weeks had to offer you know the
trump fan the trump
supporters have had a some of them have
had a hard time
accepting the difficulty of the fact
that joe biden is going to win
and you know a lot of people have been
saying there's fraud and all this
i the thing is like there really is no
evidence of that at all right
and look we're going to recount all the
votes so just chill out we'll count out
the votes but
there's no but like anyway so here they
are outside
so here's trump supporters outside
nevada
where they're telling the vote saying
count the votes
and here they are in pennsylvania i
think this was in michigan oh this
and the first might have been arizona
actually okay well but
i guess you'd have in two different
states two different states yes yeah
yeah
stop the boats
[Applause]
that's amazing yeah so the duality of
man whatever i mean it's like
that's everything it just kind of goes
to show just
things are a little silly sometimes
aren't they let me watch that again
i mean it's like come on guys nobody
likes me do we want to count it or do we
not want to count it
because trump tweeted last night i'm so
blurred on time i don't know if it was
last night the night before he says
stop the stop counting votes
yeah he tweeted out stop the count and
at the moment
if they had just dropped everything and
stopped right then he lost
so yeah he was like are you sure are you
sure you want that
stop i thought that tweet and i just
laughed out loud i was just like this
i didn't know how else to react it's
just funny
well when he said that it was kind of
like he was in a better position now
it's like all
over but yeah tuesday night you know i
thought he would a lot of people was
like
oh he he's going to win
[Music]
scary to watch and i i read that um
like it's funny everyone was saying you
know the posters
are one thing because everybody in the
polls was like oh it's going to be a
blowout
the las vegas odds guys that's the real
place to look
because after tuesday night trump had a
75
chance to win really yeah that's all
i mean everybody always talks about how
the the vegas bet stuff
you should pay attention to but um well
i'm kind of being a little facetious no
but a lot of people say that
unironically and and i don't really get
it because it's
much more just they want to make money
yeah exactly yeah
and i mean the fact that it flipped to
trump 75
at one point just goes to show that it
doesn't really know what it's talking
about right like
because well it's not it's not
infallible it's just it's just live odds
but yeah a lot of people
cited is like don't pay attention to the
polls the betting markets well they're
right i think the pollsters lost a lot
of [ __ ] credibility
for sure i'm so sick of these polls like
just
here's a poll none of us won't care
about you no one of us like you
100 responded if you really
want to know you're just going to have
to like go travel
the usa and see for yourself i feel like
because every time we talk to people who
do travel they were like oh no
this country is like half half there's
like so many trump
when i talked with andrew from august
yeah that's what i'm thinking he was
like i think
trump's gonna win yeah everywhere i go
outside of la yeah
everyone's like trump trump all day yeah
but he didn't
and we finally got the result so woman
on
oh so here's a this one was [ __ ]
phenomenal
fox news been having a full meltdown
and a little bat you want to give the
background on this because you seem
pretty you seem pretty knowledgeable on
sharpie gate before i watch the video
you then angel angela dan yeah dan
oh yeah they're making this they're
making a big stink about sharpies being
handed out in arizona and
i guess the the conspiracy theory is
that they purposely gave sharpies to
trump leaning areas so that it would
bleed the ink would bleed through and
therefore
invalidate the uh the ballot uh but it
turns out that
not only is that like a completely
regular thing in arizona it's like
written into the rules like the election
rules
of uh you can use a sharpie you use a
sharpie sharpie is totally fine it's not
a problem
so this woman thought she stumbled upon
this huge voting conspiracy
because she was given a sharpie and this
as it unfolds you will enjoy up until
the very end
you told our producer there was an issue
with how poll workers
told you to fill in your own ballot what
happened there
so um here in arizona look how disgusted
you have right now is the use of a
sharpie pen that was used at the
different polling places
um on the democrats own website here in
arizona they actually say
do not use red ink or permanent marker
because this may result in a false read
by the ballot machines
so that comes from their own website so
when we showed up to polling stations
they only gave us sharpie markers i
specifically said
i don't want to use a sharpie marker do
you have a regular pen she said no
i only have a sharpie this is the level
of desk this is the level of desperation
that fox news
has been having these past 72 hours to
try to cling on to any like
narrative of fraud or because they've
been really desperate to push this whole
fraud thing
and i guess sharpie gate is there but
you know sharpie gate
such first world problems i went to the
poll and
she only gave me a sharpie and i was
like well i can't if anything else and
she was like
i only have a shark if the sharpie would
make their vote involved then that's a
big deal but
it's that's not gonna be yeah well bring
your own pen then if you care about it
so much
well to be fair i wouldn't expect to
have to bring my own pen to vote
i don't know you expect them to have
stuff for everyone you know how many
people are going to be there
throughout how does that usually work i
haven't gone in person to vote in so
long
usually there's like a i don't know
pandemic time
bring a [ __ ] pen your own pen right
leads through to the other side she said
don't worry about it you've been doing
it all day it's not a big deal
so we went ahead and used sharpie
markers you run it through the machine
at the end when you get done
voting you run it through the machine at
the end and then what happens in arizona
is you can go to this website to track
your ballot
and from what i have seen and and it's
not just me
it's like all of i have groups of
neighbors and friends
that as well this has happened to but
what happens is that was choreographed
yeah it was choreographed it is um some
like for me
personally it says i'm not even a
registered voter now and a lot of people
it says that sharpiegate unregistered a
vote it hasn't been read it hasn't been
counted it doesn't okay
and all those people behind you did they
have a similar issues
yeah that's the best thing ever it's
like a uh it's like a jacobian meyer
like lawyer like we will if you are in a
sharpie accident
call us at sharpie and meyer 1-800
sharpie but what happens is love how
they float in there check our
ballot we got our girls back sharpie
gate says that it
is um some like for me personally it
says i'm not even a registered voter now
the sharpie unregistered at a vote
so this was in maricopa county which is
where phoenix is in arizona
and um it actually turns out i didn't
even know this until i just checked
right now the manufacturer of the ballot
machines
the tabulation machines uh the
documentation on those machines says the
preferred way to mark a ballot
is with a sharpie hmm sharpie gates
you know i got you got to love these
conspiracy theories cause it's like
got him because everywhere everywhere
it's like sharpies are fine the poll
workers like sharpie is fine that
manufacturer's like sharpie is preferred
and meanwhile she's still on fox news
like do you this is a news network you
can't fact check the whole sharpie thing
right like
right but no they got to make it a
national outrage and that her and all of
her [ __ ]
third cousins you know what i mean
we're giving sharpies which is what the
manufacturer recommends
this guy has no face i don't know to me
it's like i come from israel
he's got no face where's your face
the mask creates some interesting oh you
know what it is it's like the huge
chin yeah yeah but it's just
it's pretty funny i mean it's just kind
of funny
what are we saying about israel it's
just funny to me because
coming from israel is like no one's
gonna have anything for you
you think you're going to be going there
and be like hey
give me a pen please and you're lucky if
then
anyone will even offer you a sharpie or
anything right you know what i mean
so it's just so funny to me that's
interesting um
she only had a sharpie and i wanted a
pen
well it's even it's even beyond that
because you're supposed to use a sharpie
and the lady told her that okay how
about we i think we all
know bbq beer and freedom man but if not
let's enjoy
as i mentioned we are not prepared to
give that number come on twice that will
steal the election
the media is covering up the fighting
cards that will steal this election
the video is covering up the money crime
family stealing this election
is coming up can i point out something
about this guy yeah freedom comes last
bbq and beer first he's got his
priorities
brother bbq first
damn it i don't care if i'm living in
nazi germany as long as i can have my
barbecue
and then my beer and then three freedom
is third
i love this the mask on the chain
vibe yeah that's that's some good
spreading vibes right there
that's good spread energy
we want our freedom for the world give
us our freedom joe biden
your body is covering up this election
he's stealing that
thank you i'm out peace
where were we what was the last question
you know
this is you know what this is this is
the triggered the whole like triggered
libtard thing of like the girl like ah
i've been trying to make this argument
like the last year that the whole
the whole script is flipped these these
are the sjws now
dude you're such a little triggered boy
like saying it looks like gus
johnson's yeah well gus actually made a
video
with the barbecue beer really that's
perfect
because everyone i guess was gonna tell
him that
we want our freedom and our barbecue and
our beer
you met you can take my rocks but you
cannot take my barbecue
anyway it's a chiang dye person when
it's not
a chin diaper yeah chin diaper
the amish ride for trump i didn't know
that apparently the amish support trump
are they even allowed to like use a
voting machine
as long as it's not electronic dude the
amish of
riding their wagons for trump that's
crazy well the officers are
super conservative so bro that's epic
mmm i kind of i think trump should have
won actually now
i don't know the amish we're writing for
him look at this i love it
dude he's riding a bull i didn't know
you could even ride a bull
this motherfucker's on a bull dude do
you see that
just like that on the street oh oh yeah
if i saw this before i would have voted
trump
[ __ ] on a bowl is that normal
dude like you god i love the trump flags
so good
the amish thing i mean i heard trump say
you see them
with their boats and the trucks i didn't
hear balls i didn't hear
uh i didn't hear carton wagons we love
the carton wagon group
you know the amish is so funny to me
it's like they decided some point
like in the 1800s they're like
technology stops here
and no more yeah it's like what's the
big deal with electricity you obviously
got a [ __ ]
you built a wagon you got machines or
some kind of like they got the wheel
the fashion too yeah the wheels pretty
hot that's good technology
um used a digital printer for this trump
2020 sign
that is very true why don't they make a
hand
hand drawn sign that would actually be
really cool are you
really telling me that the amisha
cruiserweight of the sciences make
liberals cry again what
i thought they were kind-hearted people
these [ __ ] are vindictive
that's yeah i didn't even notice okay
okay seriously dude these amish are
crazy
lots of contradictions here you know
what you know how
people were saying there's gonna be all
this voter intimidation i think the
amish that guy in the bowl was trying to
intimidate voters
that's like the that's like the version
of their riding around on a tank in a
tank
you see that that's voter intimidation
right there
[Laughter]
on a ball [ __ ] nobody rides a
bull
that's definitely like the equivalent of
writing a tank
i can't get over the almost trying to
make liberals cry again that just
assumes against their all
philosophy yeah
is this i don't know this is 20 20.
bro what the [ __ ] all right i feel so
powerful
my my condolences to the amish
oh man trump people praying and center
their ener yeah this this was a weird
one
for sure so a bunch of uh they're just
outside
praying that the that he'll win
apparently
by the way and again this is very and
not that there's anything wrong with the
the uh muslim faith but like
these people probably they're they're
out here praying like to [ __ ]
mecca
what are they doing and and and they're
the kinds of people that want to do the
air ban
they are they're just losing their minds
they're such a weird
picture
of
because i thought they were all about
like being like the new woke
you know calling out all the [ __ ]
with cueing on
like what are you talking about who is
the trump people now that like
follow cue anon conspiracies oh you
think that's
woke in their mind aren't they like the
new like
not maybe not woke but like their new um
they're on to all the conspiracies
yes yes they're like they can make up
their own mind
they're not following the sheep it just
seems funny to me to also see them do
that
oh you didn't expect a couple of ricky
tikki tatas no
they are they're definitely the same
people these people are deep and cute
oh yeah
you know what i one there was an episode
that i opened where i said by the blood
of the lamb and it got demonetized right
yeah i was like by the blood of the lamb
well it was just because in the very
beginning that's where they draw the
line
you can't curse or say anything
controversy in the first 30 seconds so
apparently by the blood of the lamb god
trump's spiritual advisor this i i so
i don't know if you know either but all
the presidents
always have spiritual advisors who they
like
pray with and do all their rel it's very
it's like a long-held tradition for
presidents
this is donald trump's spiritual advisor
she has direct access to the president
victory victory victory who's praying
for
by the way i love this guy just walking
aimlessly behind her
like he's lost his phone
he's got a blanket back there angels
from africa right now angels being
dispatched from africa
africa right now africa right now from
africa right now they're coming here
they're coming here this dude's like ah
where am i
in the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here
they're coming here oh she's absorbing
all the angels from the rest of the
continents
hey they need their angels too you
greedy [ __ ] not right now they don't
let them have their angels she's making
a spirit bomb like goku style
and all the angels
africa needs the angels okay we're not
the only country in the world spacious
what is this
they're coming here they're coming here
from africa
from south america angelic forces
angelic reinforcements
reinforcements reinforcements
[Music]
it's because you become so like
overwhelmed with the spirit of god that
um
yeah i recognize the ricky dickey yeah i
think it's called evangelic
evangelisticism right dan it's like the
really
well it's more cop there's a lot
protestantism there's a bajillion
subdivisions so this is
i don't know this is the ricky tikki
tata branch of christ
some of them do the talking in tongues
things yeah
which is funny because that always seems
like something that like a satanic
ritual
in a comic
there's a dude aimlessly lost on stage
in two buckets of water
okay she kind of sounds like she wants
to rap
i hear the sound of victory there is a
little uh here
a little red somebody for sure has
turned this into rhythm i hear the sound
of victory
i hear the sound of victory oh we need
that
let's go dude we
definitely got to turn that into a beat
i wish cardi b would sample that and be
like
i hear the sound of victory wet ass
[ __ ]
so that's the listen you better [ __ ]
question god because he left your ass
out cold this time
all this all the angels from africa and
south america can help your ass tonight
i wonder why she didn't summon the the
angels from afr from
europe you know what i mean and like
it's kind of racist to take the angels
from
africa yeah yeah why you gotta what
about europe's angels
aren't they just in the sky the angels
like why are they
related to uh they're on their on duty
over there
she pulled them out they're they're uh
on the bench
in africa alex jones of course in the
mix
who could uh what what political turmoil
could go
without just real quick without alex
jones on a megaphone go ahead real quick
on this
on this the spiritual advisor her name
is paula white and just out of curiosity
i just pulled up her
wikipedia and she has a section on
wikipedia criticism and allegations of
heresy
oh my goodness she's like
he's against the church crimes against
the church
all right oh so what was her hair see i
don't
i don't know i just saw that she has a
whole section of her uh
her article about her heresy so
she southern baptists have accused her
of being a heretic sound
i wish i had a section on wikipedia
about my hair yeah i mean let's be
honest
ethan's a heretic he renounces christ
no i don't i by the way do not renounce
christ
um okay i don't renounce him i don't
embrace him either it's like
i think it was uh socrates who said when
they put him to death he says
now now is not the time to be making uh
enemies
they said will you renounce satan
he says now is not the time to be making
enemies i don't think soccer teams said
that well then who said it dan if you're
so smart
was one of those guys socrates predated
christianity
it was one of those motherfucks but i've
always loved that
quote socrates lived about 400 years
before christ so i i
don't think it was him well then tell me
who said if you're such a wise guy
google google so the why you gotta
so google uh voltaire voltaire
that's what it says yeah okay oh what
was he put to death for
yeah it might have been voltaire
okay we're making a tangent here but
go ahead you you fact check me dammit
what the hell do you do around here i
just
i knew it wasn't socrates i don't know
who said it it's a great line
this voltaire said i said now now my
good man this is no time to be making
enemies
on his deathbed to a priest asking him
to renounce satan isn't that
awesome thank you baby no problem yeah
someone uh turned that
you were listening to the whole thing
for you
you weren't even listening to the whole
thing no i was trying to tell you what a
cool quote it was
go again maybe
i was thinking okay go ahead i sent the
discord someone made it into a beat
already
oh for real av will you read that
anecdote for ela one more time
yes now now my good man this is no time
to be making enemies
voltaire on his deathbed in response to
a priest asking him to renounce satan
i do remember that thank you all right
we got the beat play it
where is it
that is a beautiful quote and i
apologize for not listening yeah
i was trying to understand the chat
and i don't know what they're talking
about so i'm confused
victory victory victory victory victory
angels are being released right now
angels are being distracted
that's such a jam biden should play that
one
that's awesome all right alex jones
you're a bunch of chicago's
it's immediately alex jones greatest
hits
you're a bunch of fascist commies
that will be defeated
[Applause]
[Music]
usa usa usa
right into the mic holy [ __ ] i'm right
into the mic with the megaphone
alex we can hear you you don't even need
a megaphone man you got a hell of a
voice
i feel like if he ever needed proof of
aliens
he's an alien he is one that
[ __ ] is undercover
not very undercover though
everybody buy my new product it's uh
it's it's
it's alpha mega brain it's like an alien
that's actually making a parody of
humanity that's great
head on over to infowars.com we're
selling uh
quadra brain it's filled with uh arsenic
lead
[Music]
and paint chips was his the one
that that turned out it was like
ninety-five turn the friggin frog's game
he's like
he's like 90 soy oh
what that his products are yeah he was
selling yeah he did he was selling it
it's just the fact that he's always
talking about how soy
feminine and hello rowan is finding out
a good point what's up with his hairline
yeah he's got a wild hairline that's
true i was thinking about that he's got
like a really wha
he's got a really wild hairline
the dude's got like a yamaka cup yeah
hmm that's a conspiracy theory on its
own
does he wear a piece does he wear what a
piece
who the [ __ ] would get a piece that
looked like that yeah
no that guy's just got it down man
you got that very strange he got that
infowars cut
head on over to info awards we got the
best barbers lego hair
they're saying we literally lego hair
lego hair
yeah what look like
a lego character that's funny
head on over to infowars barbershop
we've got the best barbers we use hedge
triggers uh vacuum cleaners and uh
flamethrowers to cut your hair
the globalists want you to use scissors
we don't believe in scissors at infowars
barbershop
just like king george king jordan people
are like
people like yeah king george
they don't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about yeah we just like the blah
blah blah
just like we defeated
and he's a hell of he's a hell of a
character what can you say about alex
jones he really is something isn't he
oh and then there was this it's fake by
the way and anyone who thought this was
real is
kind of insane i saw people were like
desperate to debunk it i was like really
it seems like it's obviously someone
just having a goof
watch
way he looks away is everything so funny
people literally think that there was a
pornhub tab
on their megatron like so what people
thought an edit
look how shittily it's keyed in oh wait
what
that looks horrible yeah people thought
it was real which is
kind of insane
it's like so poorly keyed in
the way he looks off makes it though
yeah
[Music]
oh my god yeah i saw someone posted on
instagram
like it's have you visited blocked
twitter at the market has manipulated
media like oh
my god wow
why would you watch porn on the megatron
tv to begin with
that's no place for pornhub damn it
okay well that's the election now
we have um a really special
segment lined up that i think everyone
is going to have a lot of opinions on
if you have opinions do we have pro and
cons do we need someone to ride
if you guys want to comment on this
conversation you let me know because we
kind of want a diversity
let a b know that a b no zach baby will
be the point person on this
zach is uh how do you say compromised
yeah the post is women's opinion on zach
i felt quite grossed out by zach for a
while now with a good number of other
female fans
but i've seen a real shift via youtube
comments he's creeping out a [ __ ] ton of
girls
i mean coming from me 21 female he makes
my skin crawl he said so many creepy
things that even when he says non-vile
things
i still don't want to hear him what do
y'all think are any of y'all liking this
cheap shtick still
um the comments say you can't seem to
discuss one without sexualizing them
it's concerning to say these
all of the staff all the staff
are howard stern fans i believe everyone
on the show is playing a more
exaggerated version of himself including
zach
ethan bounces a lot of raunchy humor of
sack that's a good point
this person counters i understand you're
taking on howard stern
however zach is just gross
[Laughter]
so i'm kind of curious first i wanted to
get your guys's take
zack's a good guy he's playing into the
overly sexual role for the show
we see ethan reference it so many times
yeah he seems to enjoy himself a little
too much
but i really just see him being extra
crazy and sexual for content
um let's see i'm saying a lot of
we love you zach yeah you know when i
first
my first response was uh how i mean how
dare they
how dare they speak against my golden
boy zack who
who zack of all the people in the staff
zach has a 50 year old energy
funny comment why don't we do a straw
poll in the chat just say is zach
too creepy too creepy or i like zac
he's just being himself i'm reading
comments
so so but my thing is like you know zach
of all people he bares himself for this
show
he puts himself out there he understands
what it takes to make
the show great i wish some of these guys
around here would take note
from what zack brings he brings rawness
honesty and and at times uh
he goes all out man i love it i'm 29
you got 22 female he isn't creepy it's
obviously played up
yeah yeah i think i think it's played
out i'm just giving
it just either or answer zack is creepy
or zach is
not creepy or whatever yeah okay too
creepy maybe
just i have zach is too creepy or zach
is a king here we go
okay well okay i have someone that would
uh speak against
zach yeah bring him in that's that's
kind of what i want to hear
because i think you know i think what
people do need to appreciate is that
it's hard to be so open
and not care about sharing everything
and zach
does that which is really hard it's
pretty impressive to like just share
a tick tock draft oh yeah that's why i
would probably kill myself
zack's the man you know we have uh
we have i appreciate that we have dove
in the queue
but this is it this dove i'm willing to
hear everybody i want to hear
all sides i will dove what do you think
about
zach please go ahead well okay i have a
couple of opinions but i want to preface
this by saying
my intent was to call and judge the tick
tocks
um and so
this is kind of beard into him being
creepy
oh you're not here to talk about creepy
what's happening
i can engage on the creepy aspect of the
conversation as like a young woman
but i think what tick tocks are you here
to rate
well okay do you want me to talk about
the tick tock thing
ab what's happening she's willing to
to weigh in on this it's fine that's
what i'm saying
on what we were just guessing okay look
here's the thing i think that zach has
good intentions
but i also think that zach has kind of
veered over into being a creepy dude
and i think it's in part because a lot
of the girls in the hb discord
i'm sorry i don't mean to offend you i'm
very very sorry
but the girls in the hd discord sent for
zach really hard
and i think it gives them the impression
that some of this stuff is cute rather
than creepy
and some of it is a little bit creepy oh
interesting so i'm not super in touch
with the activities
of the discord but is zach now is zach
in there
would you say is he not flirting with
people is he no
okay no i think it's just that the
attitude towards him
it kind of means that if you're just a
regular dude that's not
working on a podcast and you say [ __ ]
that makes women feel somewhat
uncomfortable
usually you get an adverse reaction
whereas zach says stuff that if a
regular dude said it
makes people somewhat uncomfortable but
because he's on the podcast and people
like him they instead go oh my god daddy
zach i love it
do you like being daddy zach zack do you
have a comment on that
exactly not food wait is a ian saying
something
yeah i was saying zach lives with his
daddy
yeah how are we going to call this act
yeah [ __ ] you ain't
zach how do you feel so i think what
they're referring to is is
[Music]
it's daddy vibes however being in the
discord
i don't know that's a little weird i
wouldn't
can we not do daddy vibes in this
discord
yeah no daddy vibes in the discord we're
banning the use of daddy
no daddy's in the discord sorry
and and what was your name uh who's on
the phone
and dove is the blame
no thanks i was gonna say please zach
please but my question she said i think
the point that dove is trying to make
zach is that
don't the the positive reinforcement you
get on the show
shouldn't translate into your real life
well yeah but she doesn't know me in
real life yeah i don't know if it really
does i mean zack's been pretty good
about not
like flirting with fans and stuff pretty
good
well as far as i mean i i just say that
because as far as i know
he is he has not engaged with that all
right thank you dove i appreciate the uh
legitimate yeah yeah
go ahead zach yes thank you for calling
it but you know
what's wrong with being honest and yes
like
i i try and be open as honest and try
and put myself
out there but nor would i want to be
creepy in a discord
or make someone dm someone in a discord
or something like that that wouldn't be
ethical
um thank you zach no zach zach's a very
he knows the boundaries he respects
women as they say he's very chivalrous
and sometimes he'll just hit a talk to
me baby when we're talking about a
little girl and that's fine
that's totally fine and i think that's
great
some early results on the poll uh with
about
1700 votes in a zap zach is a king
is leading 73 to 27
wow 27 percent about a quarter of the
audience that thinks
that kind of that surprising amount zach
how does that make you feel
that i am a king and not a creep there
you go that's my boy
zach never change in my opinion
in my opinion never change like if he
can elicit a strong reaction from the
audience no i
i think that that's fantastic and by the
way you know you know i put him up to it
always it's always like
whenever i have a disgusting question
for bell i tell
or for example i ask it through zach i
go you know
zack was wondering if you've ever been
to black
and i actually asked you know we're all
thinking it here
exactly you're well hey we're all
thinking
here yes we are wow well
zach can i talk about your sexual
exploits yet or no
no you can't i suppose i mean
no you told me you were gonna no i said
don't do don't do this
you're going to get them in trouble
exactly don't do it
oh wow now everybody's going to be dying
to know
okay well i appreciate that but but yeah
i say
what people are thinking on their mind
and i have no problem doing keep it up
that's what i say and i encourage
everybody on this crew
to be more like zach more like
zach more like that in the words of
nathan fielder
we don't need two sexs and the words of
nathan fielder he says
uh i would encourage you to be less like
you
and more like me i don't know if you
guys
saw nathan for you i'm just here to have
a good time
thank you i'm here i'm here to make the
good job flow
as long as you respect women yes he
knows to respect one does there any
other callers that have an opinion
a professional when you are representing
the podcast
on discord absolutely he does i trust
him
then i don't see an issue we have no
reason to doubt that
people are saying the poll is fraudulent
they want to recount the count
i don't think we need any pro zac i
think we have plenty of pros
they're they're all they're all pro oh
we'll tell them to get lost
sorry positive people what the [ __ ] was
with that reddit post
it's like well it didn't have that many
likes but i thought it was just an
interesting conversation starter
the reddit is just generally anti no it
definitely do
anyways so i i wouldn't oh too much as
we've talked about zach's tick-tock
quite a bit you know
they had a collab apparently a b and z
collab
so [ __ ] me dude
[Music]
i can't listen to the music so
hey man what's wrong i care about you
too much to let you become a meme
then vibe with me oh no oh no
oh no all right
all right all right oh no let's do this
the wink gotta pull the music oh you're
singing i get it
time after time
oh both of them together you edited this
ap that's a really
he surprised me last night with that it
made me cry
[Laughter]
i was i was like yeah i was so back and
forth
i'm happy his reaction was i was like
okay
abe says he didn't know we were gonna
watch this on the show and i think i
didn't know you're gonna watch it today
i needed some time to let it sizzle
that's why i didn't mention it in the
group chat
yeah you you knew we were gonna watch
this baby you even edited it you put
like work into this wait zach did you
really cry
i it made me tear up it made me feel
clear laughter
or like with laughter just everything
because peop
because people on tick tock like it's
pretty split with the comments like
they're [ __ ] mean on there
i'm super mean dude i stopped reading
the comments just because
yeah i don't like i don't get it yeah
it's hostile out there zack
he doesn't understand tick tock you know
like [ __ ] you dude oh that's stupid
you're a tick tock king dude
tick tock is for post and chris why did
why do you think they don't un why do
you think they think you don't
understand tick tock
i mean who if i'm here to to say it
say make myself divide and make other
people happy
the vibe and like you know like it's
just like
what who are you to [ __ ] judge me all
right
who the [ __ ] are you and you know i i
kill him with positivity and kind of
hold on yes but
did you play that sound played or did
someone else just
no i agree man it's it's hard being a
public figure because
you're in stage one right like the
judgment you know it's like you don't
know me i'm just
vibing out
yeah maybe i should do it
i would love that i'll do a vibe out
will you cry for me more or less than
when abe did it
i i mean a b and i have a bromance they
have a serious bromance bruin i don't
know if you're aware of the the abcs
oh you know what i was on instagram last
night and they were on live together and
i popped in
i was like the [ __ ] is this these guys
are live together
and they're talking about literally
they're going what's your favorite snack
bro
i i go zack goes what's your favorite
snack i'd be he's like hmm
i don't really have a favorite snack i
was like this [ __ ] is riveting
i don't know why we froze up for some
reason
yeah we got scared you guys are funny
oh my gosh because usually like i'll be
like oh when i live like i'll just play
like guitar and [ __ ]
and like for whatever reason we just
like we're just chilling together last
night
you guys are broke yeah is that i wish i
wish i recorded it it was just so funny
because i was like just sitting there
seeing what they talked about and just
like
what's your favorite snack they're uh
we we did one earlier in the day
yesterday and i was like falling asleep
and like everyone's like why do i feel
like abs on zack's lap
and they always make jokes about zach
being the dominant one and me being the
uh
so do you call him daddy yeah
no daddy's out there
all right but my going back to my point
i'm i'm still gonna make tick tocks
because i enjoy
them never said no one's gonna bring me
down yeah they're calling it the zab
bromance the zab damn
look at this when i saw it i saw this
one on my homepage
couch c
cow cow
c o
r are you going to the mall later that's
what i'm asking no
i am not going to the mall keep spelling
mister
c o u
c h correct
i am the smartest man alive well
how many times did uh that take you how
much time you spend
i know that movie religious oh you do i
i know that movie religiously
so i did it in like probably two takes
oh really
that's impressive yeah yeah
hey man what's wrong this is the one we
just watched
[Music]
i'm looking forward to more duets from
yeah it's exciting from you guys
exciting yeah we all should do a group
tick tock
i don't have i don't have the guts that
does
all right next up uh man
you guys are skippy is a friend of the
show skippy the virgin
currently he's been a he's been a friend
of the show for a long time and you know
skippy went off the radar for a while
um and he's fallen kind of on hard times
zach you've been kind of staying in
touch with him
what's been going on with skippy up
until this video
um he um he's having some hard times
um i tried to reach out it's kind of
hard to get in contact with him
um but he put out this video and
we're like we should reach out make sure
he's okay i know he was having car
troubles
um he uh i heard he had some family
stuff going on
he's just kind of down on his luck yeah
he's been down on his luck
i've been hearing just like he's been
super hard to get a hold of he's like a
government issued
phone or something i don't even know
what the hell but
but this people have been really worried
about him just in general people have
been sending us lots of concern about
skipping i've been trying to
keep trying to reach out but we finally
got a hold of him but this
let me give you a little update here on
skippy before we bring him on
this was posted uh all right about a
week ago
why's he have q-tips in his ears skip
what the [ __ ]
that's a great question skippy this is a
hell of a way to start a video man
i thought i was watching skippy
what what's happening skippy
i didn't watch the beginning
skippy why are you starting your video
like that
bro you know it's filming does he not
know the videos filming
he just let the whole thing ride holy
[ __ ]
is it not maybe a bit it's not a bit
he's upset i mean this is a sad video i
just didn't watch the beginning oh
i'm kind of riveted though it's like
it's like when you're watching
i feel like i'm spying on his private
moment
you know what i mean his rich
oh there we go oh he knew we were
watching yeah
15 day termination notice
october 29th 2020
to scott jessup dear skippy
consider this written notice to end our
month-to-month agreement
for renting a room at
the address i'm currently at layton utah
as per our lease agreement either party
may give written notice at least 15 days
before
the end of any monthly
rental period with this in mind
you must remove your personal items and
relinquish
the property in good condition by 10 am
december 1st 2020
please keep me informed of your plans
given the circumstances i am willing to
refund your portion of the deposit
should you choose to leave november 1st
please contact me with any questions
i've attached a copy of the 15 day
rental removal notice and the checkout
cleaning list
as well best wishes to you in your
future endeavors
sign my landlord
this was delivered to me this morning
between uh 9 and 10 am
again october 29th 2020
uh which is today
you know what's also today my birthday
so skippy's been having a real [ __ ] time
and he's been having trouble with work
and stuff i mean
i've just been like damn he's such a
good guy he's such a sweetheart
and uh i always really like skippy
and i just hate to see him down on his
luck like this so
i've devised a plan i want to help
skippy
in fact i just want to first of all
catch up and say hi to skippy
skippy are you on discord is he here no
he's coming in on zoom
and uh he should be hopping on any
second now
so i've devised
a plan for our friend skippy you know
it's been too long since we checked in
with him
the last time we talked to one of them
was when uh kyle the virgin
oh my god that feels so long ago kyle
the virgin crossed the line with skippy
and um and we never we haven't spoke to
either of them since
no that's not true well we've had a few
little things with oh yeah no that's not
true at all he did the whole damn
you know you went to science for us no
sundance who cares
what's the difference
yeah we've done little segments but um
yeah i just felt awful sad to hear he's
he's been having such a hard time and
like he's disappeared off the internet
and then we're like try to contact him
for weeks and weeks there was one point
where people
like thought he was gonna like hurt him
people were afraid he was gonna hurt
himself you know
like here here's the one video the last
video where people got really worried
about this from three months ago
we all get this way and so another flat
tire
my channel has not
been people been wondering where he is
priority lately it's been trying to keep
my sanity
because of all the crap that i'm going
through
before i went to bed last night i came
out and uh
checked my bike because
uh i wanted to
be able to you can bring him in if he's
ready just bring him in whenever
i just get on my bike and go the next
day
and my bike was uh completely fine i
just barely got
on uh my bike just now and if
you look down here uh boom that's pretty
solid right
and uh yeah okay oop
that's not supposed to do that that is
not supposed to be
squishy like that so yeah
i have a flat tire on my bike
and uh
i work about two miles away
bad reviews on that third house it's 90
something degrees right now
ouch so
uh yeah this sucks
probably not going into work today
you feel like i'm watching a um an ehow
[Music]
video
oddly riveting content
dan do we have skippy i could i could
watch him pop
i can i could watch him pump up a tire
all day but i'd rather talk to him
oh he has a tremor
oh
geez poor guy
[Music]
well
all that's left to do is call work and
tell them that i will not be there
i sweat this much and that was just from
going out
and trying to pump up my
i am a bike that's pretty good editing
disgusting that's good editing
yeah that all that sweating is just in
the last
10 to 15 minutes
dude he wraps his phone in a plastic bag
to keep it dry from the sweat
that that's pretty serious
well i'll describe the plan since uh
there's some issue getting skippy on the
in just a phone okay um
should i dance no but
everyone's saying this is so sad they
want to know how can they help skippy
don't worry
we've got a plan we've got a plan um
i've got a plan guys and i think
everyone's gonna be really happy with it
there's a couple people here who donated
to us and they want that to go to him
you want us to donate to skippy you know
well there's a hundred dollar donation
you want us to
okay we can be your conduit you know
he has a venmo thing if you want to
donate don't do that kind of stuff
because that will get really messy for
us
yeah yeah control wait what's his vent
he has his vent
which here it's just at i
am skippy one word spell it
you can donate to skippy at
i-a-m-s-k-i-p-p-y today
skippy here i'll do a i'll do a free ad
read for skippy
thank you to i am skippy for sponsoring
this episode skippy is
a man who's down on his luck he got a
flat tire he could have making it to
work that day
and he also got evicted on his birthday
that's why i recommend going to venmo at
i am skippy
to help support this beautiful mormon
virgin
he sweats a lot but he's a sweden he's a
sweet man and he's good with god
this meeting has been ended by the host
yeah
our zoom got bugged somehow so we're
having all kinds of issues today
i'm just making a new one that should
resolve it wait let's try oh you're on
you're my computer
no go to sky ab skippy uh
vedbo today to help support this
beautiful mormon virgin
hey um can you help us with reading some
donations too
i'm restarting the zoom right now today
is the day that we have every bug
nothing works is the h3
that's for the beautiful live uh dead
air cast everybody
okay okay look in the meantime how bad
would you feel if i went to p
right now i don't care nobody cares
about anything anymore
i am gonna i'm hacking your computer
right now to get you back okay dan's
hacking my computer
he is entering me into zoom
he's moving my mouse around i'm
connecting join with audio
whenever dan's in my computer i feel
like i'm being hacked by an indian
scammer or something all right oh we got
skip
we're getting we're getting everybody in
here we got a b back
this is the greatest show in the world
it's real it's authentic it's raw
it's wrong in the meantime as you get
that set up i want to present to you
trisha paytas doppelganger two
trish has paid us too trisha paid us
to this what like she's part of like a
ai series
so look at this face you know by the way
we reached out to her and asked if it
was okay if we showed these pics so
i was like i'm not comfortable just
blasting this random girl out oh you've
wait
someone found her on tinder or yeah
tinder was how it originally yeah not
one of you guys right
no somebody posted this on the subreddit
right yeah it was on the right
eva says she doesn't see it but for me i
was like dude that's
uncanny wait eliza doesn't see it
wait isn't trisha also 29 or she 30.
about the same
thing what are you talking about did you
think that looked like trisha you said
it you didn't think it did you never
showed me this
that totally looks like isn't that crazy
yeah
look at this oh here or not well yeah
from here the first photo does not the
other two
you don't see it in the face well you
never showed me this oh
that's all right rectified the zoom
situation
we have skippy on the line are you ready
bring skippy and let's get him in
standby
skippy experience okay
does it does he have the skippy are you
there here let me pin skip's video he's
coming in right now
skippy
skippy
all right we can hear you can't hear you
now
try to if you try to stay still because
you
you're coming in choppy skip
what do i need to do skippy we've done
it all
hi first of all it's great to see you
it's great to
hear from you how are you i mean where
are you right now i understand you got
evicted on your birthday have you moved
already or not yet
uh no the i got the eviction notice so
i've got uh 30 days uh
and the notice said uh which i read in
that
video said that they have to give me
at least 15 days notice but because i
paid up through
the end of november then uh
it's november 30th that i have to be out
by so yeah
okay uh it's a
long enough story that uh
you know how you guys went through uh
your
legal thing right yes i
have uh the
inclination that to feel
uh or to show that i
didn't do anything wrong that i might
have to go that way
and so i am cautious
how much to talk about it just based
upon
like uh i wouldn't want someone to later
say
like uh oh you're just doing
this for this reason can i ask you this
yeah what are they accusing you of
that that's the thing they uh i asked
the landlord that uh
two in that video that uh
i showed you and uh her response
was essentially that uh it doesn't
there doesn't have to be anything i
signed a
uh lease agreement saying that
uh that either one of us for either
reason
can uh leave it and so i just uh
the very short version and i hope that
this says
everything without me ruining anything
potentially for myself
is uh that i had
a conflict with a roommate and
uh have not felt uh
safe here uh in the apartment but it's
just because of that one person there's
like six rooms here right
and uh the idea that
uh both when i spoke to the property
manager
and uh to the police about it because
like with that
you know well that's the thing a couple
of friends said
like uh if you literally feel
unsafe maybe you should also talk to the
police and stuff
i did and uh
we've all heard that like
uh unless you get
punched there's nothing they can they
can do
type thing and it was one of those
things of just
uh me not feeling safe isn't the same
as uh the roommate
uh like having said i'll beat the crap
out of you
if there's somebody there who makes you
feel unsafe maybe it's a good thing that
you're leaving eh
well yeah and and if i was in
a financial uh place where i could
afford to up and
now i would have been moved out but like
uh
and this is where like even when talking
about it you
uh people
you almost get embarrassed to talk about
it because
of the idea of like hey i'm the one that
got myself into
this position in my life kind of thing
it's no one else's
fault but me but i'm also in a position
where uh because of really poor life
choices and financial things and then
an emotional and you know some things
that are very much in your control
and then some things that are uh out of
your control or
some things that even though you may
have gotten the ball rolling
on with some uh bad decisions
uh when life catches up to you that
doesn't mean that
uh that it's any
better now just because you know oh well
i screwed myself over by getting
by not handling things emotionally the
right way so i've got
horrible credit right and uh one of the
things that drew me to living here is
that
it's a month to month rent
but and so that gets me around the like
having
to uh have great credit with another
place where it's like hey if you've got
the
uh down payment and you got the rent
right then they don't do the
credit check so that's how i was able to
get in did it didn't you used to live
with your mom
was there a reason you or you moved out
yeah
well okay and then uh here's another
like i haven't
made this video uh and and i'll say it
this way and then you guys tell me
uh what you would do in fact i wrote a
list of questions
uh that i wanted to ask you guys about
uh
two of just like uh some advice that you
would give me
um with regards to my mom i haven't told
people about it because
my mom's health
has changed right and so instead of
making videos
uh talking about it because i want to
respect
her uh what she's going through you know
like uh
it's because of uh
mental health reasons that uh
she was not able to uh
to like continue to pay bills right
and uh and when that happened
uh she had to move out into an assistive
living center right and
none of this and none of this you want
to like talk with people about
that and the person that helped her
yeah and so like uh they gave me
uh some money uh like
her and her financial person uh gave me
like
a thousand dollars to get going uh
you know to help me on my way but i was
also experiencing like so much
emotional stuff like uh almost to the
point where i became
epileptic about it of like wait i have
to move out of my house in
less than two months and at the time i
was
uh i was going through
the uh i'd gotten addicted to opiates
uh wow and oh my goodness
yeah and uh and then right before my
40th birthday
i became suicidal right and so like six
months
or five months later when uh
when this was happening and i was
getting shown uh the door even though
they gave me a thousand dollars my
reaction was like
okay uh but a thousand dollars without
a uh for sure or without a job without a
place to live with
a car that is crappy like
yeah what do you do with that and so
like uh
and uh so my dad who himself
needs assistance uh because his body's
broken down and he uses like a
um you know walker to get around even
though he's
mentally great and even
even as i'm talking with you about this
part of me goes oh wow
how much of this stuff do you want to
share but well i mean i also
feel like but i understand your
restraint for sure
well and one of my questions uh that
i've written down
for you guys is essentially or is uh
what things
do you guys find on uh
the podcast and on the channel that you
feel uncomfortable talking about right i
mean like
though one of the last times i was on
there was the cougar hunter guy yeah
yeah
that was the only thing a little bit
yeah
the short answer is really that you know
the more the better i think
you know the more you open up i'm just
i'm not telling you what's
i'm not telling you what's best for you
i'm just saying in general if you want
to
interact with your audience and people
to be invested and i think people just
appreciate honesty and openness
the thing is that people have been
seeing that you've been going through
stuff but
a lot of guesswork like we've been
getting a lot of emails and
messages of people who are like worried
about you and it sounds like you've been
going through a really rough time man
and i'm really really sorry
it was difficult because uh i was at the
point where i go
okay uh you know we're all experiencing
covet right that's uh nothing
unique to me or whatever and when you're
going through your
kind of ups and downs uh
having a point where
you wake up and it's tough to go in
to work because of like uh
related things you know or uh depression
which we all have but
then to make a channel or try to build a
youtube channel of it i then just was at
the point where you know what let's wait
until
uh after the election because and this
is one of the questions
uh that i have for you guys too is there
is the idea of
uh how do you guys address politics with
it because
for me one of the things as i was going
through it is that like
uh some of the people i would turn to
the most
i have been butting heads with uh
politically and so i would ask you guys
how do you deal with
politics is it worth it to you to uh
alienate 40 of your audience by
being open about what you think about
politics or are you
just like hey i'm not going to go there
at all and my kind of decision was
between
the stress and the not wanting to turn
my channel
into i think that's a very less uh
important thing for you right now what i
i think most importantly is like if
you're going through so much of this
stuff and you know you mentioned that
you were at one point suicidal and i
hope you're not anymore and i hope
you're feeling better
no i'm i'm always from it but you also
know that as the
uh and you had an opiate addiction my
question is are you ready to lose your
virginity
oh that has a great thing about covet
for
and i mean this in all sincerity this
would be the topic of one of like the
first
videos getting back is i have loved
the uh the stress-free
things that have come from uh
the kovit of staying away from people i
mean like i've
got my face mask you know everyone you
dodged the question skippy
no i i'm saying that you're a man that's
that's
allowed to masturbate i remember you
said that you're you're
there's a difference between shouldn't
and don't one hundred percent
because i remember that your church
leader or something would say uh
you would have to confess if you ever
jerked off and you were feeling guilty
about it
do you feel guilty when you masturbate
uh
yes and no uh i like anything else you
try and do
things in moderation right like if i was
how many times you beat off a day
level with me a day no it's uh like uh
twice a week
maybe okay that's pretty good would you
do it more
would you do it more if you didn't feel
guilty
uh no because even
uh during this time when i've been away
from people
like the less that i think about sex the
better
it's been for me because what were you
going to say you come on that blanket
skippy
no so so i've got this
covering the window here right yeah uh
because i hadn't experienced for
when it gets uh late and it's dark
outside but light in here
yep you don't know i had an experience
where i wasn't sure
if uh if anyone outside
could ask accidentally i know what
you're saying
you don't want people seeing that it's
nobody's business
on a night when i was like oh crap
there's a really good chance that they
may have uh hey skippy
heard or sing because a friend or a
friend could be
do you watch me throwing a party do you
watch porn when you beat off or do you
just use your imagination
you know uh porn nice dude you're
becoming a modern man
nice you should feel proud of that you
know you've already you've lost
everything in life the man the least you
should get is to beat off whenever the
[ __ ] you want
like what do you have to lose you know
what i mean god will forgive you
how much though do people like in all
seriousness uh
and i know you guys are remembering you
beat off as much as you goddamn well
want this is america
how often do you beat off well do you
mind me asking
no i don't mind um probably about the
same as you but back in the day
i mean like twice a week yeah these days
probably about twice a week
yeah but but we're a little bit older
now back in and i'm married so you know
i have
i have access i think i think i'm older
than you though
yeah but back in the day when i was like
when i was like
you know a teenager i think there was
times when i would probably beat off
eight times in a day oh my god
yeah don't ask like you guys don't act
like you never beat dude
i'm just saying like on the maybe three
four
i'm just saying like i've if like my
life's
record i'm not saying that i regularly
beat up eight that's
trying to tell me it's not a lot deck
that's not a lie come on when you're a
young man and you're full
uh it was like 10 something like that
dude your nuts will fall off there's no
way
well no it no no it it starts to hurt
and you wonder why you're not
saying at a certain point no but you do
it anyway because you're bored and you
got nothing better to do i would say my
record is probably
four okay and you want to try four as
well maybe
ian or i'm with dan yeah i mean
lucky numbers yeah me and zack but you
you literally start to feel pain
from the emptiness that's what i'm
saying like it's certainly loses the
enjoyment
zack says that's the best part
after a while it gets compulsive it's
like it's not even for pleasure it's
just to pass the time
so my point to you skippy is that beat
your [ __ ] meat until it's raw bro
you know what i'm saying but but yeah
but skippy what kind of porn do you
watch i'm curious what's your preference
um i guess uh
the kind of girl this is so weird to say
uh like
when i was in high school right uh
and that's when you're discovering uh
puberty right
yeah uh and i'm not saying high school
age girls i'm not saying high school age
girls like
uh 25 uh to 30 year old-ish
kind of thing but just that idea of when
you're experiencing puberty for the
first time
i would say that i look hot young teens
or uh for girls that were
uh in my range to just slightly out of
my life you're looking for
young memories that's the category
hot young teen college
college uh a senior college-aged girl
stereo
hot young teens cool
well i'm really happy to hear that
you're beating off that makes me happy
but like now but now like i mean god
damn you better have some pleasures in
life [ __ ] you know what i mean
well yeah but i don't want that to be
what my youtube channel is all about
yeah
well no i don't think many no i no i
wouldn't make your whole you that's not
really an identity it's just something
you kind of have fun with
so but does that mean that you're okay
losing losing your virginity before
marriage would you do that now with no
no i still uh i still want
to wait for that but like uh covet has
been
great for me in the not feeling any
pressure from anyone
or anything because like skippy are you
just not going out on dates it's
everyone that's not going out on a date
skippy do you worry that
you might lose the window to have sex if
you wait too long
no because that's not what sex isn't
what's important to me
it's not okay and like just being blunt
when
uh especially the other bad thing about
uh porn
is that uh for both men and women
like the more you watch it the more uh
you have
unrealistic uh uh
expectations yeah yeah expectations yeah
but i mean and
like i am not a well-endowed man in fact
i would say i'm at
the other end of the spectrum right and
just the fact that
uh i might have a channel where i have
ever
talked about that you know where it's
like oh if a girl says like uh
that she loves my youtube channel and
i'm like oh cool
have you heard about the video where i
just kind of like looked down and was
like
uh poor whoever has to marry me
you know i mean like that's uh
i don't think i don't mind now how to
how
are we talking are we talking like three
like plus or minus three like
because at a certain point i don't think
things are minus like three inches
are we talking like how small because i
mean
at a certain point i don't i don't
you do you think you just do you think
you could penetrate a woman is it so
small
because there's like medical conditions
yeah you could penetrate a woman
i'm just trying to get a game no this is
this is horrible i'm saying uh the idea
one of the reasons why i've never said
exactly
uh the size of it on
uh lying is because i really
love the idea that i only want a couple
of people in the world including my
doctor
my wife you know and uh
you know accidentally the dude outside
the window
yeah and the dude outside the window i
mean like i don't want there to be very
many people that uh
could describe it in any way kind of
thing
and that's something that uh like every
time that i've even
uh in the past and i really really
really
have uh changed this about myself like
in my
mid-20s to like uh around the time
that i because what was i was 26 or 27
the first time i ever masturbated right
and as i started uh talking uh
dirty with girls i never did the
you show me yours i'll show you mine
kind of thing because i didn't want
uh anyone to be able to come up and say
oh uh i've had uh
if there was like a fame poor kind of
thing you know
of a person being like uh skippy's lying
about being virgin i've slept with him
and if i were to say
oh yeah well describe it kind of thing
you know it's like nope no one's seen it
i think that's right
yeah no one should be able to describe
it okay
it's a closely guarded secret
it's one of the closest it's one of the
closely guard i think you worry too much
about it though i think i think women in
general are really not worried about
penis size you know what i mean
but but if you're watching these dudes
with anacondas and you know that yeah
yeah that's the way you go on a date
with a girl you know
then um
yeah some of those dicks are really big
i
they don't put guys with you know
the mid-range ones on they don't put
guys like me in there i'll tell you what
i'm on the bench
okay well here's my plan skippy because
we all love you
and we want to help you out and we want
you to be able to just
masturbate and be happy and just
have a safe and happy home here's what
i'm doing i
i didn't know you had a cameo but
yeah do you guys have a cameo you don't
know come here do you
no but here's oh here's skippy's camera
you should join cameo and let me give
you my link to join
and that would help me i'm not doing
cameos thank you
but what does the affiliate link do wait
what does the affiliate link do for you
uh whoever uh
sends you the link uh and if you guys
were to join cameo
let's say you put fifteen hundred
dollars per cameo
as your price right yeah i get uh i
would get
five perc that's awesome dude i didn't
know cameos like a pyramid scheme
cameo yo and by the way i appreciate the
hustle skipping because on the back
you've got your venmo
and cameo yeah i am scared so here's the
plan though
yeah go ahead go ahead show that off p.s
thanks ethan heal and h3h3
we already told everyone your cameo
venmos but here's what i want to do
oh cool i am pledging now first of all
i'm i'm telling everybody
in the audience to go to cameo i am
skippy
and help support our boy get a cameo
from some schools
i think i should charge i mean 15 is
good maybe 10 maybe 15 is a little steep
what do you think 10 is probably a good
range i thought
you think 15. i had a little bit of
sticker shock when i saw that it was 15.
yeah
i think you should maybe drop it to 10
oh really yeah well i mean
but maybe not now i mean
yeah well here's what i play keep it at
14 skippy here's what i'm pledging
today by the way you have 47 reviews
five star everybody loves it
yeah because my video i do like around
five to ten minute long
uh videos for people like that oh my god
yeah i could just pay you to be my
friend yeah
here's what i'm pledging to you today
okay go ahead
today on the h3 podcast after dark
i ethan cline here with my wife eli
cline
hereby pledge hon what was that movie
the hundred
days of summer what was it 500 days of
summer 100 i
hereby pledge to buy 100 cameos
from me i'm gonna buy a hundred cameos
from skippy over the next uh
what do you think dan a month i mean i'm
i'm that's a lot of
should i just give him the money maybe
maybe for a hundred
well why give them the cut i just van
mode skippy a hundred bucks
you did dan
i don't want to clog up the cameos but i
think people can get some really quality
cameos from skippy if they go to
i am skippy all right i'm just going to
give you 1500 bucks
yeah no way are you kidding me i'm doing
it because we love you skippy and we
want you to be happy
i'm going to send you 50 but i do but
you know what here's what i'm going to
do
i'm going to send you 1400 bucks because
i want some [ __ ] cameos for myself
yeah so i'm gonna buy i'm gonna give you
you know what i'm gonna give you 1500
bucks and uh and i'm not gonna be i'm
not gonna screw you on the hundred bucks
okay and then i'm gonna buy a bunch of
cameos because
because skip you know this is a good way
to keep up with you because we've been
having a hard time keeping up
we just buy a cameo man if i'm like yo
skippy where are you
yeah yeah you did yeah wow
that all right these notes right
literally the first thing that i wrote
down that
one of the biggest problems that i've
had like uh
the last two months where i've felt
guilty about
being away from social media like i have
is uh
that uh not being able to
have yet expressed my gratitude to
people that have supported me like it's
something that
weighs on me a lot because uh the
uh when people have been sending me
you know like five and ten dollars like
in the past on my videos i would the
very next video
uh thank everyone that had right but as
i've been
going through this like uh not only have
i not been making the videos
i've had all these wonderful generous
people and i haven't yet reached out to
them to say thanks
and part of it has been like uh like
between anxiety of living situation and
then like losing job and and just
all the weird things that go through
that but i feel horrible for having not
said thank you
so much sounds like you know thank you
guys so much you need a break there's a
lot going on you know
times are hard for a lot of people in
like sounds like it's been hard
all that stuff it can be a lot too but
trust me h3 nation loves skippy
h3 nation the fupa trooper army we ride
for skippy
and if that guy in your apartment is
here right now
i mean obviously physically
sound very good no i i have 24 000
subscribers right
and of those 24 000 i would say easily
20 15 to 20 000 of them came
from you guys like i still remember the
day that uh
you guys made that video of me and it
changed my life i went from
having 1100 twitter followers to
uh 7 thousand and it went up and down a
little bit but it's still around seven
thousand that's because
of you guys and like when are you there
they click on the who else does this
person
uh watch it's always you guys
telling you skippy we're gonna keep
choking in on you guys
a lot of people in the chat are saying
check your van mode too
check your vamo right now actually dan
can i send him
can we can you do you have access to my
paypal i
used to during the help thing i don't
know if well
let me see let's see what let's see what
skippy's got in the venmo we can i don't
know what people are sending him but
i know that h3 army is generous and
prosperous
we are
paypal i think you can paypal venmo okay
yeah it's update oh
i i turned off my i'm trying to save you
1500 right now
cool we gotta i mean i
i turned off my uh sorry i turned off
the internet so that no one
could send me a message while i was
talking to you guys uh
so now it's refreshing holy sh
wow what's in there
uh i can't see it's right there what are
we what is it
1072.19
all right wow the hell out of that
apartment
we ride for skippy you know i've i've i
just felt so bad
you're such a good guy you have such a
big heart and you've always been such a
a good sport we just hate to see you
down and and
uh we were missing you so we're going
what can i do to thank you guys
nothing there's anything to feed off
don't listen to him completely okay i
want you to
add a third day to your cycle i want him
no we just don't want you to
um to feel like it's all stacked against
you
and yeah let's come in with some good
advice you know just if you guys like
making videos
then now you don't have to worry so much
about rent and all that stuff you can
you know this is going to help me get
know what you want to do
i just don't want you to feel like
you're alone out there and that you know
that no one's got your back because we
got your back all right
um you guys are thank you
i i don't know what to say oh i had a
funny thought that came
uh even i will uh when i
make my tithing slip out to the church
and i uh
okay you know i don't give the church a
penny of that [ __ ]
in the comments like of uh when
when you do that there's a little
comment section right and i will
put as the comments for uh under
donating
i'll put four beating off and i think
that would be
church i don't know if they'll accept
skippy does the church really want your
your money i mean you're not a rich man
like why do you got a ties to those
to those people well the uh the church
was how
i've been uh surviving uh
until now like through this like
literally the
uh when uh when i was suicidal
and then i moved up here and i was
staying with my dad and i couldn't find
a place to live
uh the church of jesus christ of
latter-day saints my bad my dad reached
out to
a bishop for people that are 30 to 45
years old and said hey i have the son
that's going through a really tough time
and when i uh met with him
he said uh it sounds like you've been in
a really dark place
uh we would like to help you get set up
on your feet that is awesome so they
then paid my rent for the first
six months wow when i lived here
including they
uh provided food right like they let me
go to the church's
uh food system and then they set me up
with the job that i've been at for the
last
uh 13 months months 16 months
you won't get over i'm a fan of the
church
you're right they they earned that wow
no you guys
thank you so much i all right i don't
know how
i'm going to check in i'm going to check
in with you next week and i want to see
how it's going then because i think the
cameos are coming
in yeah they're getting out they're
coming in yeah we're going to we're
going to sauce
we're going to we're going to keep the
love coming so we'll check in with you
next week you just take it easy
look at some hot young teens enjoy your
day and
uh just keep just keep doing your thing
all right don't stress
i really wanted this to be a funny fun
conversation i hope that i wasn't a
debbie downer for you guys like
uh you are you're you're you're you're
you are authentically skippy just what
like i expected yeah don't worry about
it
yeah um this is the feel good all right
i'm going to check
i want to check in with you next week
okay is that okay thank you guys
so much thank you so so so so so much
for this
all right i i i don't wow all right
we'll talk to you next time
take care take care bye guys bye thank
you wow
so first of all thanks to the super
tuber nation always so generous
i'm gonna go have to ghost drop him
1500. yeah i tried i
i think it's just a different login for
memory you've got to link it or some
[ __ ] you know
but i'm actually i know it you guys
think i'm being silly or whatever but
i'm really happy he's beating off
because like imagine it's just it's not
good it's just [ __ ] up
like especially a guy who's so down on
his luck like and
who's a virgin and he's probably got all
this pent up like he last time he was on
the show he told us that
he was he he would never beat off
because he felt so guilty he had to
confess and i'm like
come on the dude you know what i mean
like let this man have some pleasures in
life so
yeah so that makes me happy and i'm i'm
really happy we got a hold of him
super trooper nation always rides or
dies that's great
why is everybody spamming cash i don't
know i don't understand sometimes i get
so confused by the chat because everyone
will just start spamming something oh
are they asking for his cash up i don't
think he has a cash out
he's just they were saying check his
cash out but i didn't know if they were
memeing or not
because they were saying check all that
no it's hard to follow sometimes oh god
you guys just sending money out to
[ __ ] the void
do you even have a cash out where you
guys said i didn't hear a mention cash
app he said venmo yeah i want to tell
you guys
you just said i appreciate the
generosity but
oh just sending money to the void
well that was pretty fruitful that was
fun
yeah it's tough to hear that it's been
going through so much
yeah i've just been i've been honestly
really worried about him i'm really
happy we got a hold of him
you know in these times it's like it's
it's just so
tough when when there's people like
skippy's such a good hearted sweet guy
and when you don't have a support system
and things are going rough it's just
your everything can fall apart so easily
you know and he's done so much for us so
let's keep it going that's about it
though for this um this week we i assume
we've been going for a while dan
and um good weekend to escape you on
cash app
yeah he's on patch
somebody's
no people are saying that it it said
cash app on his back wall i guess
so okay good i guess he's got that tag
too okay
thank god what were you saying damn no
a.b was talking
i was saying the same thing dan was
witches
all right so there's a trillion other
things to get to but um
we've been going for about two hours
we've done two hours yeah
and i'm ready to i've had a long [ __ ]
day y'all
long long day but i had fun i think this
was a great episode we covered a lot of
ground eh
yeah despite our inaugural uh vmix crash
here that's fun yeah i'm gonna have to
do something
thank you guys for sticking around yeah
thank you
did you did people really not like me
asking about his penis and stuff i found
that really interesting um i feel like
people think or were thinking that maybe
you were taking it too far
i wasn't being rude i'm like genuinely
intrigued by everything about skippy
i think you sometimes go a little
too provocative maybe when you ask him
like about the size
oh yeah well because i'm just trying to
get to the root of the issue because he
clearly has some kind of
because like it's like dude you don't
have to worry about your penis size you
know just get out you know what i mean
like women don't really
guys so overestimate the penis issue
i feel like yeah but i guess it's just
the way you asked it
it's not really you think oh well but he
seemed happy to oh
he seemed happy to oblige me yeah
i want to know more about skippy's penis
and you guys just got to trust me as the
host
well because there's a difference right
because my point was like are you
talking like
three four inches which is like on the
small side are we talking about like
micro penis
where you can't even like penetrate a
woman which is a medical condition i
just want to know what i'm dealing with
because i'm trying to
i want to i'm on team skippy you know
what i mean i want to advise him
i think it's liberating for him to talk
about it
we know you're saying whatever you know
ethan thank you zach the only one that
understands me we know you mean well
it's just that the room
wasn't up vibe we know you wanted to
feel comfortable but this
isn't the time because he was uh coming
off of telling us about all of his well
i was trying to lighten it up you know
i was trying to lighten it up
and and talk about something fun like
penises
ty i love how forthcoming was about his
porn choice too that was awesome
hot young teens man popular category
love it i don't even want to know what
zack watches i'd be afraid
for the truth to come from zach
well what does that say about him he
just he follows belle delphine but
zach what's your preferred category i'll
just go ahead and ask you
um i like milfs oh right you try
that i find that see i'm not into the
milf thing but i know it's super popular
what is it about the milf thing that you
like
uh i and maybe it's the age like a fine
wine um
i guess that would be i found that the
milf videos have like more plot line and
sometimes that can be
fun and i wonder if maybe it's that
but like do you know what i mean like
all the milf stuff has kind of like
there's always some kind of build up
about the family and [ __ ]
like you like the plotline or no zack
uh you know i'm gonna i skip around i'm
scared
yeah yeah it's like like a little plot
but then you know you gotta get the
wham-bam thank you ma'am yeah you don't
wanna spend all day i don't want to
watch the godfather on my [ __ ]
bottle of lotion you know sick you were
supposed to finish
10 minutes ago ethan i just want to
update you that
um there is a few comments okay we
forgive you ethan
thank you you know i was feeling i i you
know
i just wanted i just want to help skippy
evil started kicking me on the table
which is always a bad sign
you're not checking discord what do we
have i'm talking i'm engaged in a
conversation
you guys check it sometimes i'm i'm
engaged with skippy
stop i think i know
authentic people left on the internet
i mean i feel like that's yeah i feel
like that's that's why most people are
fans like we
it's the only place to get some
authentic stuff nowadays
thanks a.b no problem the sim strikes
again
yes sir but you know i always know that
uh
the interview is is crashing and burning
when either starts kicking me under the
table
why do you gotta say everything because
it's funny i mean it's
i was like oh [ __ ] well i try the civil
way which is discord but you don't check
it no
i i encourage you to kick me under the
table sometimes i don't read the room i
guess and you can kick me on the table
because i'm not gonna look at discord
i'm gorgeous
skippy's telling me about his penis size
that's fascinating
come on
all right let's wrap it up on a high
note where everyone stop
thank you guys another uh terrific week
at the h3 podcast
we're here we're out here we should uh
a little house cleaning uh housekeeping
house cleaning
whatever whatever the [ __ ] you want to
call it uh we didn't record our
interview with
contour points yesterday we postponed it
to next week which means there won't be
an episode on monday so don't
get surprised when that happens
we don't have anything yeah we can uh
for a monday episode right we were
scheduled to
do our contra points interview three
three yeah the day
after the election and we both agreed
like we don't know
any because it's not gonna come out till
monday so everything we say is gonna be
so
yeah it would have been so would it was
still very unclear who was going to win
the election and everything
so yeah it'll be better yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah this is ethan the
most
the most and only authentic person left
on the internet
the whole chat said abs right 100 i
agree
i swear go back i think the authentic
thing is like
it's kind of like i guess a double-edged
sword because
definitely sometimes i think people
don't realize
dan was quick on that one less authentic
dan
but i don't know i mean it is what it is
but yeah it gets you in trouble
sometimes but
yeah i always find it funny that people
would go immediately to the assumption
that you're a snake and thinking that
you're so like manipulative when it's
kind of
always the opposite you're just like
right yeah what you see is what you get
with ethan
pretty much yes too much about what
you're saying
for sure on screen and off screen ethan
is really not that different
i'm not i'm just i find the whole snake
accusation funny because yeah it's like
it's like sometimes if you were a snake
you wouldn't get into the trouble that
you get
you know
all right well let's all go enjoy the
weekend and thank you all once again
i love you all and take care and have a
great weekend and uh
you know things are settling down the
election
is kind of settling down which is good
yeah so let's just hope for a nice quiet
weekend all right
love you guys they said we wouldn't come
back
from the ashes like the phoenix on the
flex back to two
you're watching x to the three three
three three you're watching h two
three three three three you're watching
h two three three three
three you're watching h two three three
three
[Music]